morning John I very much enjoyed our
family vacation here in sunny steamy
Florida all of the people and the
scenery and the squirrel just gotta talk
a little bit while this squirrel is
extremely dogged was one of the best
things about any trip like this is
hanging out with you and so here's some
footage of that
so yesterday Hank and I discovered this
new game able topics it's not actually a
game they did not sponsor us no in fact
that's why we don't do product placement
is so that you can know that like the
corporate behemoth that is table
together that's not responsible for
today's baby also Table Topics is
actually owned by Exxon Mobil is it
really delicious Exxon Mobil Oil good to
the last drop I'm practicing trying to
write yeah we gotta get good to see a
pitchman diet dr. pepper
tastes just as bad as regular or Dr
Pepper 10 it's not for women it's for
apparently misogynist Table Topics wants
to know do you live more in the past the
present or the future I would entirely
in the present like people do it's not a
question intended to suss out Time Lords
like oh what quality do you think is
most important in to marriage end
marriage and do but look all do I think
is most important in ending marriage I
don't know cheating what a depressing
question and you marry mutual generosity
oh that's very sweet that's true John
what's your dream job oh I had this
crazy fantasy where I get to make video
blogs with my brother and write novels I
mean I have my dream job what about you
except for well but you have like a
million jobs your dream job is to have
all the job all the job congratulations
you've done it all so that is going to
be Jeff I'll just get out and then
you're just doing all the repeat that is
gonna be great that's gonna be the gin
what one question would you ask a
psychic how they live with themselves
knowing that their profession is alive
if it was a proven real psychic yeah be
like I'll me the stock market that's a
very sophisticated financial question
Hank tell me the stock market it's not
even a question it's just a statement
tell me the stock market is a sentence
that ends with a period it's not it's a
fragment of a sentence I guess it would
end more with semicolon or something
John if money were no object what kind
of party would you throw into where if
money were no object I wouldn't throw a
party I would I would throw VidCon
I like to be by myself only my family
would know I had a new I have a new
answer okay I would throw a party on
Mars object here let me ask you a few
Hank if you could be a famous athlete
who would you be this is going to
challenge Hanks ability to name an
athlete Harry Potter is a he's a pretty
good Quidditch player he never went pro
what's the most significant problem
facing the world farts
Henry what is the most significant
problem facing the world today I thinks
it sports is it lack of naps you heard a
garbage truck
I didn't Hank if you owned a boat what
would you choose to name it the dark
time bad wolf
make which piece of land would you wish
to have preserved forever
well forever is an incorrect concept can
I preserve it from the explosion of the
sod what do you miss about childhood
Dexter my ferret this was a stuffed
ferret for the record what remains
undone that you have wanted to get done
for years for years yeah for me it's
lipo the elimination of death meaning to
get to that take what one goal do you
hope to accomplish this year I hope this
year to put an end to all suffering I
would like to do a couple cool projects
with nerdfighteria so I see that we work
on somewhat different scales Hank thanks
for playing cable topics with me I'll
see you on right now I would not say the
blog by the video at the time was their
fictional my friend the bad man